I think that facing death changes people
which is what happened with me before
this experience I was a completely
different person with a completely
different dream
my last dream which was to treat cancer
and right now my dream of changing the
whole you know in another way
[Music]
[Music]
staying at the motel is this hard
transition stage you are homesick and
you are also thinking about remaining
family members overseas living under
horrendous circumstances I try my best
to introduce the new reality I try my
best to ease the impact of their
resettlement process as refugees as
someone who didn't choose to come here
as someone who had to come here hi my
name is Mohammed from immigrant services
society of British Columbia
I thought of EC contacting you regarding
your place on Craigslist we wanted to go
under you're looking at the bedroom of
the three-bedroom
welcome to bedroom two bedroom okay
that's over John yes a family of five
people with three small kids
yeah actually that is too many unelected
future well okay - oh thank you would
you vote I am with my clients right now
so I'm helping him he wants to share
with you the kids are so small and the
ages are oh oh I see I'm a little bit of
live my visa how do you believe it the
world of Londo
okay I'm gonna what about the three
bedroom that you have $3,500 and the
extension strong new immigrant family is
it possible for you to see the kids
online it can accommodate right people
in casually yeah thank you so much I'm
sorry they received my visa Hamas's huh
yeah moving to Canada is not easy at all
my job is all about providing first
language services to the newly arrived
refugees I am a person who welcomes and
I will help them use everything that
they will need in their resettlement
process it's really hard to explain the
reality on the ground in Syria it keeps
on changing on a daily basis Syrians are
just cut up in the middle of this
nonsense
chaos many of them have spent many in
refugee camp in neighbouring country
trying to just wait for this crazy war
to finish when they realize it's going
to be much longer
this Syrian refugee crisis started from
Delica al-majalah in technology highest
yes the energy to metric other than Lehi
and Nephi LaMarcus the world can enjoy
mustache our work at Mozilla broccoli
raw cotton and the Hobart INSERM Huaraz
it's under anyway yeah in the ibed era
later a lot to my dad exhibition Mimi
loves to vary widely and I'm Marcia
shark and the true international mobile
shallot and Neha the hero but Leonard
Turkey circle in greasy and higher
school with the village octave aren
member kombucha
the membership our show Aloha area
[Music]
before 2011 before everything has
started we were living a happy life I
was born in al-hasa Greece India a very
peaceful city a city of so many
languages ethnic components religious
component with the idea and the notion
of accepting others I was in my fourth
year of my medical studies in Syria I
was trying my best to become a doctor
and my dream was to treat cancer
[Music]
my generation was dreaming of having
freedom having some basic things that
the average Canadian would not interval
[Music]
we never thought we could have faced
such a brutal a very which point from
your own government just for gathering
industries and shouting the words feeder
[Applause]
we were just standing there and
surprisingly they started shooting and
people started falling
at that point everyone started running
everyone who has survived it started
training and some people were just on
the ground covered with blood
I'm calling you regarding client of
smile who are moving to your place
tomorrow morning yeah because we are in
the middle of you know arrange and also
transportation needed for all of these
families alrighty thank you so much for
Syrians it is so normal to open your
Facebook and see the death of your
friends on social media is something
that is really happened that is really
difficult to accept to absorb unto you
even think about
[Music]
I am about to turn 27 next month
in this small lifetime I have been
arrested frequently I have been in five
different detention places
the first thing that they did in the
detention center was hanging me from the
ceiling they had handcuffs on my hands
like this and they had a chain coming
down from the ceiling and they have
hooked the chain to my hands like this
and they kept me like this for three
days
after spending three days like this the
actual torture started they spent so
many days practicing all kinds of
torture only and all other Syrian people
in that detention
I can never forget this old man who was
sleeping next to me he used to say you
see all of this one day all of this will
be just a story that you will be telling
to other people
[Music]
after 120 days of torture I was an
illusionist I was finally able to see
unlike again the only thing that I
wanted to do is talk to my family
I just wanted to see them but also say
goodbye to them get the hell out of here
and never look back
I took a taxi from Damascus to Beirut
where there was no shelling no explosion
just a normal life
three hours away from where I was from
when I was tortured
it was unbelievable for me Isis of this
weekend's way good morning Syrians in
Lebanon are not allowed to work are not
allowed to go to school Syrians in
Lebanon are simply not welcomed alive so
you're allowed to longer sugar the best
job that I could find was washing cars
from 9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. for $20 a
day I was just struggling to have a life
my whole life changed with a single
phone call I pick up the phone it was
this same phone so I pick up and I was
told that this is the Canadian embassy
calling for Mohammed Al Thani
but Allah I was like yes speaking so
they told me we have an application on
your behalf to come to Canada are you
interested I was like yes I am
[Music]
[Music]
each Syrian family is thinking about
someone who left behind if it was a
brother - as a mother if it was a father
this is something that I can see among
the people that I'm helping and this is
something that I can relate to on a
personal level because of the situation
of my family my family had to illegally
cross the border between Syria and
Turkey they had to crawl in the mud in
order to make it to safety
hey Madhava la mama so as well as your
father
well Oregon stuck with lirikrip she has
your shallot Awad
[Music]
yeah we the supership sharks after we
increase when I left so my family my
youngest sister was seven right now and
I don't know how all to achieve me when
I meet her it's really hard to know that
you might not be able to meet super
therapy cause you're jealous
I'm totally motorcade mom
Ananta holla be a man Michelin Macumba -
Oh mom ha ha hyukoh family health
commissioner is Missoula grandmothers
Maharaja to follow no no no Sherlock
elimination affiliate novel on because
ha ha
voila shudders come kitty kitty kitty
in order for people to get settled and
to feel like home I think the only
missing part is time they just need time
now Monica your work yeah
have you lost one parent imagine tiny
sedl Falcon vault with a lot of
important question Michael O'Donoghue my
first client was a family of 13 people
who have just came to Canada well I say
I sent you to it and a couple developers
whether or not know about you I was
telling them you are safe now one year
ago I was standing exactly where you are
and right now I am helping you so don't
worry everything's going to be fine
I want everyone to realize how
tremendous how beautiful it is to offer
people a place to call home which is
something priceless but they really
really appreciate having right now
[Music]
it's heartbreaking to see the country
that you grew up in get destroyed
I am one of the ones lucky enough to
come back from the dead to tell their
stories to share their suffering with
the rest of the world which is something
that I think is part of my obligation
toward Syrians and towards Canadian
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]